now this is the second time that we meet
Minister zero for in ten days and this
is not a coincidence we are working full
speed to make sure that we reach this
right mixture of solidarity and
responsibility in our migration policy
this is the start of a new political
cycle Europe has done a lot on migration
but not all and together with
Commissioner Johansson we are here to
make sure that this time we get it right
especially when we are preparing the you
pack for asylum and migration which
we'll be presenting next spring Germany
is at the heart of this process not only
because they contributed very good ideas
but also because they will be holding
the presidency in the second semester of
2020 so we are here to work this time
we have to get it right and we know that
we need to manage migration orderly we
need to be in control of migration so
that we can welcome those that are in
protection of need of international
protection and also others that will
come on legal pathways to contribute to
European economy by working here for
example but by doing this we need also
to protect our external border and to be
better on returns and we need to unlock
the block situation between member
states I think it's time for a more cool
down the debate being more pragmatic
finding compromises and I think that the
discussions me and vice-president Cena's
already had with ministers II offer a
promise that German can play a very
crucial role in finding this base for a
new compromise on migration thank you
thank you very much